last night in Parliament  even by their standards  a new chaotic low  all the failures of the past 12 years  have now come to the boil  the victims of crime who can't get  Justice  people dying because ambulances can't  get there in time  Millions going without food or Heating  and none of it can drum into the Tories  the idea  that our country must come first  they lack the basic patriotic duty to  keep the British people out of their own  pathetic squabbles  and its wreck the finances of our  country and for millions of people  this cannot continue  Britain deserves better  Britain cannot afford the chaos of the  conservatives anymore we need a general  election now